WOMAN: Here's my first letter.
It tells me I got
to have re-sampling.
A month later, a little
over a month later,
again, my well water
is not safe to drink.
Then the third letter I get
says my water is safe to drink,
almost 11 months later.
[inaudible] are leading in the
nation in coal ash clean up.
This ain't leading no
nation in coal ash cleanup.
Telling people to drink
contaminated water
that you have told me
twice not to drink--
that's not being a leader.
What you have is a system
guaranteed to pollute,
a system a primitive
storage we wouldn't
allow anyone else
to do, and a system
that is primed for catastrophe.
Every day they are
polluting groundwater rivers
and lakes with toxic metals.
The companies have a
reason not to clean up--
they can't afford to and
still make coal profitable.
If you took all the profit
that's made burning coal,
it's not enough hours to
clean up after the mess
that coal leaves behind.
Coal ash is an enormous
problem across this country.
There are about 1,000 coal ash
sites with very heavy levels
of pollution,
ultimately ending up
in some waterway that people are
relying on for drinking water.
It's a ticking time bomb
for millions of Americans.
OK, what you need, baby?
Gas.
Go on, go on.
Fill her up.
Send her on down.
We know that Duke Energy is
never going to admit this,
because if they do,
there's six other states
waiting to pound on them.
We know that.
We just want them to
do the right thing.
Clean the mess up.
Clean up their own trash
on their own property,
just like they would
expect us to do.
And provide us clean safe water.
We know too much now to
turn around and back up.
And we are not going away.
[music playing]